the explosion shook buildings far away
and created a column of smoke that
spread across the Baghdad sky early
Monday evening at least one person was
killed and dozens injured most of them
civilians Iraqi security forces say
there was an explosion at a weapons
depot inside this military base shared
with a paramilitary group iranian-backed
and other armed groups had been
operating in Iraq with the full support
of the country since 2014 when they join
the fight against ISIL a new law that
came into effect on July 31st requires
all paramilitary groups to report to
Iraqi security forces or put down their
weapons other than saying an
investigation is underway and
compensation will be given to the family
of the civilian killed the government
has not offered any explanation as to
what caused this explosion a vote amar
and his family were preparing to eat
dinner for the Eid holiday when they say
missiles began raining down on their
home a window shattered a metal door
ripped apart one of the daughters is so
traumatized she continues to shake after
the explosions stop all of us run out of
the house we were overwhelmed and scared
the explosion happened here at this
military base in southwest Baghdad
rockets and shrapnel flew across the
highway and over here into this
impoverished area where more than 1000
people live
they've lost electricity and their homes
have been damaged they're angry and
demanding compensation from the
government on Tuesday morning teenagers
walked around looking for and picking up
unexploded rockets despite warnings many
people are in shock yet eager to show
the damage to their homes bottom line we
asked the government to compensate the
poor living in this slum it is dangerous
to live here now we're asking security
forces to remove these unexploded
missiles as
soon as possible boom Tamar says she's
grateful no one in her family was
injured but the damage to their home is
just another hardship in a life of
struggle machine they tell machine we
have suffered for a long time and we
keep suffering only the poor enjoy the
worst we don't expect anything from this
country that's because most of the
people living in these makeshift homes
along the highway have built illegally
they say if they could afford to live
somewhere out of range from a military
base they would Natasha a guy named al
jazeera Baghdad